à ces horreurs halleguen coa ses radis
finlandais
1 km 1 qui
cadeau c'est chine de sa signature du
motel de killeen phrase qui valide
lui-même divers cadeaux
[Musique]
je
la scène était là la forêt est toujours
d'attaqué semble hélas et autres jouets
la laisser là est la première fois où
j'ai vu pascal immo terre il était il
était noire avec x 19 aussi bien quand
vous avez un verre d'eau quand je les ai
vus sur scène improvisée à 40,88 jeter
dans le public là il était sur scène
avec une scène qui est là j'avais vu à
88 j'ai dit non ils sont pas prêt je
reviendrai dans le nord est après un an
après on est là on a commencé le boulot
moi j'ai pas changé mais je me suis même
amélioré avec le temps comme le bon vin
ça vient à d'autres pour ceux qui
auraient oublié qu'ils ignorent quelle
arrivée incroyable eric n va vous
éclairer et c'est comme ça que ça va tu
qu'elle arrivait sur le micro de vente
et de coeur il regarde
pourquoi c'est quand même un lieu très
rock qui a ouvert ses portes au hip hop
dans le milieu des années 80 c'était
vraiment pas évident du tout en fait on
finissait de comptes hier ont laissé le
micro ouvert d'auteur
eric continue amitié a passé des faces b
et qui voulait monter position qui est
vraiment l'ambiance c'est vraiment bien
si pour toi
[Musique]
les radios svindal ras du légat flux
théâtre quat'sous d'abord ils étaient 2
une émission de concurrentes et un jour
on l'a invité à venir presser anémique
il est rentré nous regarder de travers
il est rentré et il m'a regardé
immédiatement mois aux platines
il est entré comme comme il faut faire
sa place et tout ça les mecs de ce prix
qu'ils en avaient marre de nous monter
un métier on était chiant on avait la
chance d'être une radio commis c'est que
les gens étaient ouverts d'esprit après
on s'est retrouvé à l'évêché avec notre
notre notre patron en fait à la radio
c'était c'est s était l'archevêque
on était quand même dans une radio qui
était catholique à 100% on peut dire oui
les religieux sont fermés d'esprit n'ont
étés de suite après les religieux
italien jeudi hrw initiée par des chants
liturgiques y avait tout du rap qui
partent et démons c'est pas comme la
cathédrale c'est surtout
il n'y avait pas déjà te finir le disque
annoncé leur hausse et que tu ce bond de
[Musique]
59,2 jules lemaître s'est dit qu'ils
comptaient le religieux disent que c'est
yann moix brouiller la radio il ya
quelque chose qui a changé
bon à la fin des années 90 n'a racheté
les locaux d'où était fait des émissions
qui nous ont mis nous quand on avait 12
ans présent dans le rap ont débuté la
conseillère maintenant les structures
d'ailleurs qui sont installés puisque
côté obscur et s'est installé aussi
et à cette époque là c'était une maison
de 3 des studios d'enregistrement
puisqu'on a eu jusqu'à on va dire une
quinzaine d'artistes notamment par des
psychiatres chiens de paille
l'algérino
guga vendre
c'est à cette période l'as tu vas pas
l'effervescence permanent je vivais là
aussi la richesse et morceaux il y avait
là et il est là aux côtés des
psychiatres le propriétaire des lieux
akhenaton n'a pas forcément besoin de
calme pour trouver l'inspiration
pour c
tu vois que le plaisir dans les
générations de supporters et ça le le
groupe iam il est identifié comme l'om à
quelque chose qui a qui a permis à la
ville de se placer sur la carte
nous on s'en remet pas contre mais on va
jouer à varsovie il ya 5 6 ans jouait à
varsovie
il y avait quatre mille cinq cents
personnes les mecs il sorti les écharpes
maillots de l'om en pologne
et ça fait chaud au coeur de marseille
koné à l'étranger oui il avait rencontré
des policiers ce guide souvent également
membre de l'autre côté on a de la
provocation
j'ai tout à dire chez ducati en tout cas
du aussi c'est comme monsieur il fait
partie des voix que la boxe en moi je
fais partie
moi j'habite au centre et au centre
ville peut-être ces responsables de ce
qu'ils disent est pas vrai le bitume il
ya le royaume de personnes avaient un
avis et je sais pas c'est pas un cas un
autre camp maintenant dedans et un mec
commune rené giancarli il a fait
énormément de choses pour des tas de
gamins dans cette ville ce que nicolas
sarkozy a supprimé ce gala il a mené des
gamins un stage de voile
il a mené plonger les gens et leur
faisait faire du sport il travaille sur
48 cité dans le 15e
et je te prie de croire qu'un gars comme
ça il a sauvé mais plus d'une vie donc à
une époque où ans clivé on sépare les
gens je trouve vraiment regrettable
qu'en france on est supprimé la police
de proximité
sk liam est un groupe de rap ou sk yam
est un groupe de rap marseillais
je pense qu'on pourrait dire que liam
est un groupe marseillais d'europe cadet
est prévenu le fait qu'on soit ici ça
donne une couleur aussi bien la musique
coco paroles qu'on sait spécifique de
marseille s'est il faut pas essayer de
changer ça il ya une particularité dans
un jt d'identité qui fait qu'on connaît
qu'on est ancré dans cette ville et qu'
il ya une identité marseillaise qui est
qui est évidente
on pourrait exister ailleurs je sais pas
s'il aurait duré aussi longtemps parce
qu'on a été isolée de plein de trucs des
soirées des ddd tout le monde ait des
mondanités et il ya aussi une
vision des choses qui est qui est
typique à notre culture à la culture
david fass est une ville qui est qui qui
at il ya il sait si elle attire ou alors
au pouce
c'est à dire où on adore ou on la
déteste et c'est vrai qu'on a une
réputation
d'une ville mais je trouve que c'est pas
pire qu'ailleurs donc c'est surtout moi
je préfère en un genre que j'aime pas
marc s'est attardé sur les belles choses
après en privé on peut parler des
défauts et je sais qu'on a là si la
ville magnifique c'est incroyablement
beau l'avantagent qu'on a marseille
c'est qu'on ait stade premier de
développement et qui a tellement de
choses à faire de par l'ampleur de son
territoire de par la richesse de sa
population dans la jeunesse de la
population qu'on espère que les choses
vont basculer du bon côté pour que ce
soit une ville qui soit une ville
extraordinaire dans le futur et on
puisse bien y vivre
on a espoir on espère au moins de poser
enfin nous après le temps que ça me pour
construire la l2 se dit que vous devez
pas précisément tranquille au mal
tranquille
[Musique]